this video is brought to you
by better help as two people
proud to be in therapy we are proud to be
partnered with these guys for the month of
November greetings citizens of the reject Nation
it's like I'm an alien sometimes you guys are my
friends he's my friend nobody's ever getting
unfriended that's not what we do and we also
don't like the dark web but we do hopefully
like unfriended dark web cuz that's what we're
watching today sup Greg what Su Roxy sup Greg
you got anything on the dark web I don't even
know if I really know what the dark web is
it's like illegal internet stuff but how do
I get there like is there a thing that's www
but dark web yeah anyone could just access the
dark [Laughter] web why don't more people use
the dark weapons all you got to do is type in
it on Google it's right there so you're laughing
but I'm still confused on whether or not I could
get there or not I'm sure the movie will have an
exposition the movie will probably say something
to make it for people like you to be like what's
the dark web this is the dark web I've heard of
the dark web whatever if you guys also have never
been to the dark web like this video I guess if
you've been to the dark web like this video just
like the video in general comment subscribe all
that good stuff hit the notification uh and dark
web with us you don't want to encourage people to
do that no I don't even know what dark the verb
there means no but if you want to be the webest
of all webs then be a patrion that's the sexy
webs they're like web slinging webs those where
all the really cool kids go go to our patreon
for a full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy Greg and John cover
several shows over there exclusively with reaction
highlights talk about and watch alongs included
that's what's up dark BR we dark web in tonight
man I want you to not look down for a second
how long do you think my intro's been uh dear
I I've stopped having anxiety about it gotten
used to when Roxy introduces the video I will
figure out what to cut sending multiple intros
to be like I managed to cut out 30 more seconds
but I do watch every video and I see what you
cut and I like what you do I appreciate that I
like what you do too you give me plenty to work
with I have the clicker no that's the work oh
no you guys cannot see what's happening on the
screen right no it's TW no no okay in three two
[Music] one bird there's something
wrong with me man yeah yeah what
would it take for you to unfriend me
on the socials finding out you're not
actually Jewish that would be
like what a liar that would be
trash you remember that sound if you
are old enough you remember that sound
yeah I mean it's just a Mac no that's
not what it sounds like anymore right
that's what it sounded like when on my
bluec I hope like five-year-olds aren't
watching this video is your password just
P oh now we're trying to guess it maybe
try with exclamation points you're going
to get locked out maybe not at this time
period quiry what's quty I
think they're just trying
anything at that Point feel the burn big
interesting kofifi okay so this is after
Trump whoa no [__] your
password can't even just be
one oh wow the attention to detail on this
oh away I went to college with him oh
really what's his name Colin w [Music]
back on the Facebook do you use Facebook
ever not really no I had to uh go to some
event and I had to say yes on it recently
that's the story of how I use Facebook ever
okay so we're going from Nora to Matt but is
it him using the computer because he seemed
like he couldn't remember the password
for the longest time but yeah but it was
logged into Nora so I'm assuming it's Norah's
computer because that he logged into easily
test Maya is going to love
this oh he's trying to surprise
her crap this is [__]
good you learn all the right
words okay so there's aaya there's Nora there's
Maddie and there's a J unless
AJ is a place no I think it's a
person there you are just remember who has
two thumbs and gives the best massages in the
world what why isn't she speaking she's hearing
imp faired that's why he was doing the sign
language oh oh yeah did not I got a new computer
today it's much faster than my old one oh and she
can see it that's cool oh so cute that's neat
so uh when the app doesn't understand a word
you just you just type it in and it automatically
connects you to the ASL site and then there's a
video tutorial on how to do it wow there's so many
lags happening on screen right now Dam she doesn't
seem happy with this I know she seems extremely
exasperated right now from when you told me how
hard it was for you to understand me when I'm on
Skype are they just like looping her same look
can you can you type her screens are kind of
off she seems so incredibly she annoyed with
him or about some situation she's trying to vent
about I don't I think she's annoyed with him maybe
that's not what she wanted how are we going to get
into the dark web with this whatever he downloaded
must have had like bugs or something I don't
know whenever it freezes I feel like it's
the movie I like I mean like feel like we're
have to like fix an edit well the spinning
wheel of death always is going to make you
feel the editing on this one already seems
completely different though they have to do
something a little stylistically different yeah
updated technology probably was easier to match
some things but it's definitely anxiety
driven the camera quality is really good
oh no this a very odd Pace setup and they're
introducing a lot of characters in strange
ways why is he like logged into her stuff is it
her computer downloaded something on her end and
maybe she saw something I'm not sure Mary Ann I'm
so Nora oh good been working waiting so long we're
finally going to meet up oh don't fall for those
oh yeah but remember he's not logged into his own
thing this is Nora writing to writing Nora and
he's seeing it who's Nora I don't know yet I'm
you again this movie makes me be Cy I know I know
another person too I get it you're asking all the
questions I'm thinking and I'm like but I'm sure
we'll find out eventually putting what in the what
are you putting in your gas thing don't put
booze in there so he doesn't know who Norah
is damn this Norah gets around maybe it's
an alter ego of Maya or [Music] something
did you send the plane tickets yeah it's
obviously somebody is like hooking up with
a lot of people guys got this for nari for
her birthday because I guess I'm trying to
compensate hi MTV my name is Kendra I live in
Malibu I'm into blank and I love to this one
so strange I don't understand some stuff that's
happening my name is Kendra I'm from Malibu I'm
into having on top of a pizza my name is Kendra
I'm from Malibu I'm really into the systematic
destruction of an entire people and their way of
life this is part of their game I guess that they
do I can see the pores on on your face that
actually looks like you're calling from the
year 2018 I mean it's a 4 30 frames a second I
don't think you're ready for this I got a new
laptop it's a refurbished laptop and it was
formerly Nora's yeah or not refurbished he
stole it I don't think stole but maybe that's
why you couldn't figure out the password I
got some killer Bud yeah I know I heard you I
just wanted Linda to here too she's not going
to she still thinks marijuana is illegal here
damn you're going behind a woman's back like
that is going to sound like a a nitpick and it is
it cuts to the people on their on their singles
before they start speaking yeah and I'm like
that's not how Skype or Zoom works you have to
start talking first before it goes to the single
it keeps like pulling me out this one feels like
more movie yeah totally and less like I'm watching
a screen recording but we're still early so G to
wait I like that we have one of the boxes with
two people this time because at least we'll be
able to see the dynamic between the two of them
sure yeah yeah is Nora a guy wh why do you think
Facebook and Twitter are free because you're the
product they do find very natural actors oh no
they're Gathering your data man there are sharks
swiming below you they're just going to they're
going to come in from right up behind you when
you don't even see it coming and they're just oh
yeah explore that hard drive what's in there cell
towers GPS IP address detection Bluetooth device
tracking your head ah huh Bear yeah a
teddy bear in a survivalist bunker with
a year supply of food guns and ammo I want
to fix this I want us to work what happened
in your relationship whatever we just saw
maybe he didn't learn how to speak sign
language fast enough yes a someone clearly
stole this laptop and he bought B it off
[Music] on it's like all just like a Side
Story is it a story or is a random people
side improv or something [Music]
yeah so these are all things that
I found yeah I guess these are all the
people that this Norah person interacted
with cameras yeah it's all miss all different
addresses oh wait wait oh wait hold on I'm going
to play it now okay check it out I just got these
new speakers look how just whoa you guys see that
though look at my new bombs Bam Bam Bam why is why
is our guy not mentioning any of this to the group
conversation well he is talking to that one person
on the side should we wait for Amaya I don't think
Amaya's going to be coming they yeah it's my mom's
ring did you ask nar's Dad for permission and did
you film it please say you did because oh my God I
just I love the look on his face like you brought
up a sore subject I would really love to see that
that face again it was cool when you stood up to
him that's all I'm saying it's just dude dude I
don't even know the whole backstory but I felt
uncomfortable about that is your mom excited the
Cancer's progressed it's moved into her brain and
they have her own life support though and they're
really trying some aggressive treatments so this
just went from yeah he to libo's darkest [__]
just progressed in there but they progressed they
have her on life support that was a wild line I
remember when I had to put my dog down oh my God
that was my least favorite thing people would
do when my mom was sick I oh my God it's like
I get how much people love their dogs but it's
just not the same God you're so bad at this so
bad no I am so thr oh my God I used to [__]
hate that H they're just trying to keep up you
know it's a game of tops when someone dies in
your family yeah but everybody with the dog no
noa's favorite sunset this
La okay this is cute as [__]
oh answer what are you doing like I I I
know I know you're mad at me and I know
we we we've both been busy but I feel
like I know I I've been spending a lot
of time on this app but I've been
doing it why can't you just type
it that is a fair assessment yeah so
it was about that class and you never
went yet you didn't put in the effort
maybe ignore that [__] no no I'm just
uh yo stop getting so distracted Y what the hell
is up with it man Focus up Amaya obviously she
hung up you deserved that times a thousand
and I don't feel like you actually did go
to the ASL class and really have it out for
this guy no I just don't think he went what
guy has ever scorned you take it out on him oh
he's been caught no but he didn't he bought it
off Craigslist that person he has to he has
to have known it was a stolen laptop though
why cuz of all the [__] that's on here it's
like not cleaned out of someone else's personal
stuff that's G
gone oh he doesn't have one he did steal it oh
did he actually steal it maybe it's weird the
first movie had such a solid easy to follow like
setup in the first like 5 to 10 minutes of its
characters and the drama and what's possibly
at stake and then here it's been like a slow
reveal to understand what's going on I'll leave it
where I found it I'll go now why would you steal
it and then bring it back it's like structurally
very different yet stylistically super similar I
think he's going to actually bring it back and
then that person is going to like torture his
friends where are you going yeah yeah yeah
I I'll I'll explain later all right bye then
is everything okay sometimes that going so
is Norah's like this like super hot lesbian
prostitute maybe she leaves it out for it to get
stolen on purpose to mess with [Music] people is
an NA I guess what's this guy's motivation
exactly what's that his friend is like not
asking anything like why are you asking me
all these questions wait what's going on you
want to share share your screen mate oh this is
where all went wrong all right that's that's an
overlay Network you're being bounc around around
everywhere so no one can track you dude this is
darket It's where you find market places for bad
[__] basically like um I get it but how do you
get there the river you need certain devices to
access it I've never accessed it looks like an
old school BBS Charon it's a Fairman of the
Dead the Fairman of Hades who carries Souls
of the newly deceased across the river stes
and so real yeah dude whose computer did you
buy there's a cyber cafe that I've been that I've
been working at noticed this computer was sitting
in the lost and found for the last 3 or 4 weeks
wait wait hang on you stole someone's computer
because I wanted a better computer to work on my
app with and then oh your theory might be right
when when I went on Facebook all of his stuff
Auto filled it's a fake name guys it's Charon
backwards nah he's the smart one he's one of them
and whoever they are they must this is where they
meet up to trade I get rid of that computer
and stop sharing the screen one of them was
actually sending me private messages earlier
it was Shon 68 poor schmuck never made it to
69 I hope that was not scripted I was looking
around and I found this uh this folder right
it was hidden invisible and it's got videos
960 gig show us why are you still on this
River thing he is very intense that one guy
that's here that's the one's on the east side
and oh they're hacking people's cameras
hackers drive through neighborhoods trying
to scoop up Wi-Fi addresses of any unsecured
or vulnerable round so they can hackers can
activate the camera on laptops and phones
and disable the indicator lights so you
wouldn't even know that they were on damn did
you open that link in the folder the one called
account wait that that's just from
a couple of minutes ago it's crypto
currency that's $10 million
guys we'll take it it's almost
11 free money just sitting there no no
there's no such thing as free money AJ
facts [Laughter] there's there has to be a way to
just take it they're trading on the dark web via
Bitcoin ask for more type uh for what no
no I have no idea what he's talking about
want tration the sound effect of whatever
something went through is hilarious a surgical
procedure in which a hole is drillen to
the skull oh you do it to yourself oh
[__] oh ah this Nora person's
awful oh isn't settling in a very different
way because it's praying on something very
real Sharon 68 the first thing he wrote
was that he liked the last contribution
go back to the video folder and scroll
all the way to the bottom or filter to
date created first no Matias don't open it
please no just open why would you want to see
this oh 45 minutes yeah this is the
rest of the movie yeah and it just
never log off I just want to keep watching
wouldn't they be able to trap track where
the laptop is that's horrible this is
really unsettling why is everyone so
quiet I think they don't know what to say oh
God oh my God they're going to bury her alive
it's really good at being very creepy without
showing much okay now I can't I can't it lets
you fill in the rest it's really clever yo our
homeboy seems way too curious about all this I
would not be I would I would stop what would
you do though call the cops I get rid of the
laptop yeah get rid of the laptop and then what
I would call the cops yeah get rid of the laptop
take it to the police they need the laptop take
it to the police okay what am I going to do with
this show me the most recent one Nori let's not
forget there's got to be a supernatural element
to it because there was the first time yeah I
don't think that means that there has to be this
time right they did have that deep the Charon
thing whatever that was wa stop this can't be
real set up a camera in the
house to break in and do
that see if I can see who did why is he looking
at the camera that was it right yeah yeah yeah
yeah well then he might not have her yet oh that's
why he chooses a girl shows her to the rest of the
group and waits for someone to pay and someone
just paid we have our address so just we can do
a reverse phone Lookout you think they going to
go after Amaya I feel they go after Amaya but no
they would know if that was her bedroom though oh
no oh no she's not trying to get a hold of him go
to her house Kelly someone's broken it Kelly oh
that is creepy hey hey hold on one second damn
I'm SOA with you right now no I mean I just got in
I think Amaya's in the shower you possibly get it
for me right now wow I can hear you are you still
can't see you there's a lot going on I know the
editing is jarring in a weird way sometimes it
serves it and other times it's whoa what the oh
noell oh my God [Music]
K is he still logged into
Skype yeah I think this entity travels via
this way what do you mean I don't feel like
it's a person really going I feel like they
travel via through the screen in some way
you don't think they found the Amaya's
address okay I hear what you're saying
it's not NE I don't know that it's
wrong it's not my interpretation so
far and she's hearing impared you know like
it couldn't have been her messaging cuz she
was in the shower don't go in there don't go
in there don't don't go don't stop stop stop
stop okay oh my God [__] it must it must
be a a bug or something your your computer
called mine um uh Kelly Kelly just type it say
something she brought a she brought a guy home
he's she's don't don't no don't disconnect
I'll I'll wait for you I'll wait I'll wait
for you my God is he not going to tell why get
there call the cops do something what this is so
weird why is he just sitting there I
this is so confusing I don't know yeah
I'm a little bit some of the choices
are a little odd please please just
please don't hurt her I'll do anything
you want me to do I will do anything I
promise a Black
Mirror yeah that's how I think he found a Place
whoa that Distortion of the screen is really odd
yeah so they're here to save someone's
life wait just one second can you wait
if all he really wanted was a laptop
he would have got it from the coffee
shop I don't think this I feel like this
is probably some type of entity 100% or
he was lying about it being at the
coffee shop for weeks and he took it
dude he can see you messaging that we called
the police or what we're not calling the police
we're going to the police okay but you need
to trust us no get the laptop go down to the
police station no I have a friend that will
meet us he knows how to deal with this kind
of situation it's not real oh my God it's a
g it's a game I I I made the whole thing up
it's a game Lex you were you were totally on to
me from the beginning oh he can't he can't tell
them the truth right right holy [__] I guess
that means it was pretty goodas this is not
[Laughter] funny it's it's an alternate reality
game exactly yeah I love how he's appreciated this
idea where'd you get those videos that is some
dark [__] yeah no I know it's just um horror
film horror films what if we'd call the police
ideally you would you would register to play
with your your cell number so if uh by the time
you logged in you called 911 it would hack your
phone and you would get a recording like like
the bad guy your phone wow he is a masterful
liar especially in a high situ he didn't
the laptop wasn't actually sitting there
[Music] for now convince the m to come to
you now the story Line's much more in depth
how it builds this this this special bond the
ability to to communicate with with someone
in in a special way that I'm really scared
am I oh my God what this is just so much or
any the way I care about you the night we
met at the bar music was was so loud and
a beautiful person wouldn't be able to hear
you anyways it's so loud that all that noise
wouldn't matter that's what I want for us
nothing else to matter I want nothing she
seems happier her smile is a good indication
I need you to get here as as fast as you can
okay take um uh take take the subway okay
oh no man this is a desperate isolation
situation Lex mute your m
you are louder than her all the actors are
good I just don't not really as connected to
the group dynamic I don't really know W they are
and why they are the way they are well they seem
like better people fair enough you know what I
mean sure I'm gonna be honest I I was totally
there but they he can see your screen
oh [__] that's who was [Music]
messaging wow he was one scroll down
from seeing all this say if we had
decided to do something with the bad
guy's money if we' taken it then how
does that Ripple through the rest of the
story what is he thinking about with the
money oh yeah I think I think he's trying to
[Music] threaten good and watch this cinematic
glitches I they Bitcoin is the cause of all bad
things oh my God can you just do that apparently
[Music] yeah dude you get the computer back
when I get aaya back you get the money back
when I see on the news that Erica dun is back
home safe uhoh stupid mother all I want is my
laptop all I want is aaya you don't understand
you killed Kelly no I didn't if you lay a hand
on a Maya shut the and listen the people I work
with all the other Sharon primes they monitor
all Bitcoin accounts they're going to think I'm
trying to cash out oh great so now they're going
to hurt Amaya it did feel like a a little bit of
a a rash move what's going on what's Happening
I I I I I don't I don't know oh my God now he's
got to work with this guy you know what I'm just
I'm going to close it no do not close it they're
going to know you're not me are they talking to
you what are they saying oh my God they're saying
they're saying recite the code oh God just put a
bullet in our head you stupid oh my God the
voice is disappearing he's becoming a human
being if they find out that I lost that computer
they're going to kill me they're going to kill
you and they're going to kill anyone else that
might have seen just give just give me the code
what you killed no I didn't I just bashed your
head she'll wake up and think it was a a robbery
or something we have no time for this they said
this is your last chance Sharon for Sharon four
type A B Y SS u s wait they're typing in all caps
should it be in all caps just send it why did you
join your account tell them I switch from Bitcoin
to ethereum I would said I'm switching just use
his exact words you're asking why it's a better
exchange rate I got a tip why don't you sh this
a verb if I let Erica go they're going to lose
Faith they're going to hold me liable but you'll
have $10 million to help you figure out how to
disappear if anything goes wrong between here
and there you're both dead he's just going to
kill him anyway like why wouldn't he just come
and kill both them he's obviously willing to kill
anybody so I found the girl from your video she's
real her name's Erica Dunn ladies stop where did
you even get the video Live Leak yeah some someone
on the inside just must have must have leaked
it or something I don't know why would you use
that video yeah he's like ladies cut it out stop
style it back trying to save a life right now oh
great oh we're back to the first movie how do we
get this person off does anyone know how we get
this person off wait what's going on come on Maas
oh [__] the dark WB people have hacked them the
link do not click the link you hear me guys we
didn't click the link but the video is playing
anyway oh no what the where's Lexi senior year
that's December dash at mcc's puia oh that's
so scary that is scary what I mean they yeah
they're revealing how they got them yeah wait
guys where's Lex oh I know she's probably still
getting theing Le they're College friends okay
where is she okay I am is she
in on this masas what's going on
oh oh
no is that Lex must be oh you guys are all
dead like a th% how close how close are you
to the subway can you stay on the call just
just keep your keep your phone in your pocket
or or or whatever just just just stay on okay
yeah who are you calling I'm calling Lex don't
listen to me for a second right no no more calls
all right we just uh you can you can leave your
phones on feel this person stressing yeah yeah
yeah hang up the phone I'm not I'm going to call
the police right now calm down give me one more
second please me one more depending is real the
whole thing is real oh my God he can hear and see
everything all right he he he found a my apartment
she was the first person I called so he must have
been able to track her somehow or I don't know I
don't trust to have one guy I feel like it's a
big Ploy what okay the guy who's like who took
the money from the Charing guy the laptop own
how do you know he's not listening now because
of because of Facebook Chat the green light it
goes off when she loses connection that's why
I told her to take the subway what about the
other people when she went underground then I
could tell you guys what was happening all right
look there's there's no service in the station
oh they're hacking his the computer via through
there okay it might have happened when when he
didn't have connection or oh [__] no he's got
a girlfriend or wife right mom was upstairs I
think I don't know that he said he didn't want
to smoke in front of Jesus Christ mom what you
mom Maddie you are so dead what
the please oh my God couldn't he have
send a text message no he's his phone
is not connected though he said he was
watching him though they have cameras at
his place so uh who wants to go first oh my
God I'll go they're being so awkward be be
better actors she especially like I don't
want to put up with this [__] right now
my gym teacher got fired for adding blank to
the obstacle course too much cocaine velcro
depression I like velcro thought
depression was pretty good all right I'll
go is you action comedy Jackie Chan must fend
off ninjas while Al hey uh nari we're trying to
play uh a a horse with no legs her boyfriend
show up going going around punching people
and where's Lexi oh they didn't see where Lexi
went wow yeah give me access of laptop assist
preferences users in groups add user Make sure
you give me administrative access you guys my
friend on the force is coming over here no and
you and your mom get the hell out of your house
you're the only one who might not be safe Damon's
in London they can't get to him and nar's got a
friend on the floor so so the cops are already
on their way I'm being in London doesn't feel
like a oh no um did it break down or did they
do something to hack the subway Serena nari
Serena guys hello all cuz you stole a laptop
dude Nar skipping this round how much longer
how much longer for where' the subway break
down let me let me just let me ask Purge go
on where did you break down in my bedroom uh
Western Boulevard that is in Hollywood what's
going on with nari bathroom she's not feeling
well it might be a while what was that it's the
cop the way of AJ so sick and tired of all
you sheep will not they're going to show how
they're going to find him a storehouse of assault
weapons and explosives weapons and explosives
weapons oh this poor guy with the conspiracy
theory Channel having this all happened to
him oh how would have taunt in maneuver the nature
of your emergency I am sick and tired of all the
corruption sir is this a real emergency I'm going
to pack up all my assault weapons and explosives
go downtown to the mall and oh how cruel Jeff Co
is a family name wow that was just so recent they
made that call 10 minutes ago AJ you need to we
have no I just get just get on the ground oh my
God they're going to kill him oh oh wow what a
cruel maneuver right here what's on the screen
Illuminati they're into his computer oh they're
they're lo oh my God they're putting things on
his computer they're downloading stuff they're
downloading oh my God they're going to download
gunfire or something they're going to play it
well oh my God oh my God oh my God I knew it
no no stay no aent oh they're so taunting oh
that's so mean [Music] no that was horrible to
watch that was the worst one yet oh my god
wow they're like going up against a secret
society yeah they [Music] know as soon as the
train reaches the station no nari is on her
way there no oh my God I can get there faster I'm
going to go now oh they're all getting a the great
words John Humphrey ug the other people didn't
deserve it I don't think this really matters on
the deserved no the other people more deserved
it but it was still like these people are good
Oh you mean the movie they me the people the
here no you want to not tell them tonight or
or no it's perfect because this way Dam gets to be
there for the news AJ will be fine he's a big boy
um quickly do they scan their [__] you would
love that or with a boom box just John style we
can't hear him but he's trying to talk they're
only daughter so my mom no no she has what are
they playing this back I think they're about to
go find her at the hospital this about going to
be about her mom and we can bring the paperwork
and in I see you she'll be our witness yes yes
you're going to say where she is I don't want you
to have to choose between me and them it's not
fair they're going to make her choose between her
and her mom or something y oh she's going to get
pushed in front of the train TR be her or her mom
I think it's going to be a choice yep there's her
Mom they're going to try to kill one of them and
make her choose which one's to save yeah who would
you choose her mom is going to die yeah so you
choose your girlfriend it's horrible but that's
what you do no no no no no I will do anything
stop this right now I will do anything oh man
so in control I love how there's a personality
to it I think they're going to kill both
regardless no no I won't demonstrating
as much strength as you think you
are no oh that is cruel [Music] wow oh man
that guy behind her is just going to turn
around and push her Dam yikes would the guy
also die looked like that he's there Serena
Serena get out of there right now Serena
get out of there right now oh my God yeah
see the way they travel though feels like
not real I think there's just a lot of them
listen to me I want you to listen
to me whoever I'm talking to right
now nobody's listening to you honey
the guy who lost it he's he's on the
subway train with her he's wearing a gray
hoodie this is all his fault okay she has
nothing nothing to do with it man what an
unflattering shot I had seen that in the
theaters her whole performance this whole time she
yeah speak in sign language that they don't
understand I'm sure they could interpret it
oh my God no they're not going to
be able to he needs to just talk to
her slow I really got to learn sign language
you going to get him man yeah I am well just
make sure you leave the computer because
I got to keep downloading the video files
okay do you think he's in on it how
great would that be you're there aren't
you bait laptop guess what I've been recording
you should have dealt with mathas who was going
to give the computer back but that is not what
I'm going to do this is everywhere that computer
has been this is going to lead them to Erica
and every single go you took you're going to
come right into his place right now Photoshop
oh they're going to photoshop his face on it
they are so evil I can't get
over it man oh my God how
cruel they just have some like weird
ability they're going to plant things
there they're going to plant the girl it's Erica
done do they have some like weird software
enabler on their their bodies and their cells
that can he didn't lose the laptop Shon 4
he left it there deliberately he wanted it
to be found they all wanted it to be found it
was a lure yeah dependent on him it was a lie
they're setting us up we did everything they
wanted us to do we moved the money we copied
the videos they're going to make it look
like it was us the whole time oh my God was
a my head on it I'm almost I'm a second away
I'm a second away no way inside where inside
where you're home but we had our first kiss
Amaya ah Maya I I I didn't I didn't send you
anything oh this poor woman is papaya going to
help no oh my God they think it's him damn why'
they choose these guys to pin it on to cuz they
saw him at the shop every day I don't know this
is such an icky ass experience cuz they knew Damon
was a tech guy so that he have the capability when
they looked into it oh my God they're at his home
yeah oh the confession
letter holy [__] how clever
cuz remember he downloaded it
all what a proper setup oh she's in the
room that with the canister initially
remember yeah but how do they travel like
this there's a lot of them is game night
they can sneak up though game night
game night oh she's here a bear too
yeah oh this is their game night oh my
God this is their effing game night wow
how many people that's what I'm saying
there's a lot of them is it the girl from
the first movie no it's er done why
would it be the girl from the first
movie the drill yeah oh my God don't
pull it out oh the horror of that let
him die it's going to be die and then
it's going to cut yeah so many now
yeah see like how does he not hear a fan coming
his [Music] way remember they
have to show their faces every
time that's the like insurance policy [Music] yeah
women two game night wow that
was wild cops in on it that was
wild well it's interesting there's not a
supernatural element this time I didn't
think there was going to be cuz dark web I felt
like that makes it more susceptible to have a
supernatural element you know things happen to
a lot of people in this they do man honestly I
think that there if any of them had made it out
alive there' only be one solution for them oh what
was that and they need to talk to somebody talk
to what like a therapist clearly I need to talk
to a therapist you need talk everybody needs to
oh you know what that actually gives me an idea
if you just step out of the video for a second
I could talk to the audience I think it's really
important to play them and they come right back
and we'll act like we never even lost time I got
you today's episode is sponsored by better help
I know that we often joke around here quite a bit
on the channel but I wanted to speak a little bit
more sincere during this specific sponsor and I'll
start off by saying this that you know with any
sponsor they usually give like suggested things
to consider uh when talking about the sponsor and
one of their suggested things was was a question
that they had there that went along the lines of
like have you ever laid awake with your thoughts
racing wishing for a moment of silence and I
thought to myself well yeah that's my secret
cap I got know that feeling way too well and it's
in those Quiet Moments where you're battling your
own mind where you are seeking Clarity the most
and you may have heard me talk about this on
the channel before the better part of a decade
now therapy has undoubtedly been one of my main
anchors before there was ever the real rejects I
was diagnosed with PTSD type 2 bipolar and ADHD
so uh needless to say I needed some therapy and
through its guidance I've Unearthed deeper layers
of myself cultivate to richer relationships
and just have a more profound understanding
of my emotions and one of the best parts about
it is it's giving me a space where it's free
from judgment where I found my voice and learned
the art of truly listening not just to others but
also to myself I've talked a little bit about how
this year I've focused a lot more on my physical
health and hit in the gym a little bit more often
and in all sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place where you can
really nurture your mental wellbeing and it is an
experience that has been quite transformative
so much to the point that you know I would say
at least half of the people that you see that come
here on the channel are in therapy as a matter of
fact I know one of them their therapist is with
better help I often joke that like I've been in
therapy since it was underground why I joke like
that is because I I see now in the past few years
a lot more people have been going to therapy
which is fantastic I'd love seeing that so I
will say that if in your heart if you have been
seeking therapy or contemplating going to therapy
I highly encourage you I urge you to consider
better help before I ever saw some ad for better
help I had heard other people who had been with
better help and had really given strong in-person
testimonies to me their online platform is crafted
with care keeping your comfort in mind starting it
as simple as answering a few questions and really
important to remember it's a journey and I really
love this because I've had uh at least like three
therapists in my life so if you ever feel the need
to change your therapist better help understands
and allows it without any fuss trust me that's
a massive benefit so for a journey of Discovery
and mental well-being turn to betterhelp embark
on this heartfelt Joy at betterhelp.com that's
hp.com Rejects and embrace 10% off your first
month genuinely thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video it's weird I thought the
first one dealt with a more serious probably a
more relatable subject matter for more people
and yet and and something that was a much more
sensitive subject I think the first one the just
like the the premise of like go kill yourself
on the internet go un alive yourself yeah yeah
and the cyber bullying and all that like the like
dark web activities are very much real um however
I think like that one's a little bit more yeah I
would say I would say like a little bit more like
you you can connect with that or empathize with
that more because we're a little bit more privy
to that last name was written house yet I thought
the first one I walked away with like that was
fun and this one I was like this is a really
uncomfortable experience well the first one
was targeted right we know why by the end why them
this one it's just like you know things happen and
wrong place wrong time and they pinned it on them
for funsies just scary creepy true really creepy
oh such a bummer for Rebecca written house why
because of Kyle Written House oh really I don't
know I I don't think they're related I'm just
saying I wouldn't want the last name of anyway
you should see my friend Steven dmer yeah I
think that would be a that would really be
a balber yeah um or George Hitler you met him is
that real yeah he my neighbor May serious no oh I
could have kept this big going for a while that
would be crazy um yeah I would have changed my
last name if my last name was Hiller yeah I would
hope so I I think I'd be like don't have a sense
of Pride my friend this was really creepy they did
a good job it was different it felt like different
editors because we did spend a lot more time away
from our computers in this one yeah you know like
there with the flashing different videos and stuff
we did do that last time too though and I like the
dynamic of having two people in one yeah but the
the fact that none of them had like wronged each
other and it wasn't like as much about that and
more was just like we need to pin this on you guys
creepy yeah I think structurally I I feel like I
could have used a tiny bit more like in the first
like 20 to 30 minutes I found myself just trying
to play a little bit of keep up with what's going
on wait what did it just say the story name are
are all fictitious oh fictitious yeah okay what
do you think it said I don't know usually at the
end I find at the end of things I didn't know if
it was saying like based on a true story oh yeah
yeah um I think I think in like the first 20 to 30
minutes structurally there were I could have used
a little bit more kind of a personal investment in
in these in the people first it like CU there
comes that point where he stops to break away
he's like yeah there's something happening on my
computer I bought this computer off Craigslist
there's this thing happening and that's at like
the 30 minute Mark in the movie right and I I did
wish that we kind of got clued in a little bit
more to the personal Dynamics between them other
than just sort of the surface level stuff yeah
but I I I definitely hear you but I do think it's
interesting that you were asking significantly
more questions than normal and I think that was
maybe the purpose like the first one was much more
straightforward this one wanted you to Fig have it
unfold as it's unfolding for them kind of I agree
I I I I do think that there was a a world where I
could have had because I was more just like I was
more focused on like understanding the information
and plot and less so having like an an emotional
investment and that but that emotional investment
eventually did come around at like the halfway
point in this movie um and I think the world
of it was very well done at first I was sort of
getting the impression that they had stylistic
choices first that they wanted to toy with and
then they were building they like the filmmakers
yeah and then they built a narrative around
that versus the reverse you know I felt like
there were first leading a little bit to surface
with like its gimmick and what other neat way can
we do it but then eventually I really started
to feel like the story at of it all and the the
intensity of it unfolding like I I think like as
it escalated I love I really love the escalation
of it like when the dark web Circle people came
in and just started hacking their Skype chat I'm
like that is really scary I thought that was
genuinely a really scary and felt more that
that felt more like uh real and tangible like the
the last movie you just start going like it's got
to be Supernatural like you just feel that it's
probably Supernatural and then this one I think
that's why it's a little bit more icky because
even though the subject matter in the first one
is a lot more sensitive this this feels like
there's a world here where [__] like this
actually goes down it kind of reminded me of
purge like at times with like the the and like
just being their game night as we were getting
towards the end it kind of did feel like that
do you think that you would Black Mirror meets
Purge yeah yeah do you think that you would have
thought that this was cuz the whole time you were
like there's got to be Supernatural angle if it
wasn't for being a sequel would you have thought
that no I would have thought okay so it was only
because like usually in a franchise they kind of
stick to that same level of Supernatural whatever
that level is yeah I mean there there are times
here where it becomes a little bit I don't know
honestly the thing is I really really don't know
there are things that register to me as SciFi I
would say like like the Glitchy cameras every
time they walk in the room kind of thing I just
think that there was something in their pocket or
whatever yeah there was something there that would
happen in on the text messages when it would it
would delete it would always have the like this
jittery thing and whenever they talk to the chat
the the charin there's always like thud sound
effect whenever they enter and I couldn't tell
if that was a filmmaker choice or if that's what
our character was also hearing on his end of the
screen there were there were things about it where
it would feel sci-fi to me which would make me
think of like a black mirrror um and that's why I
would sometimes be led into thinking that there's
probably something Supernatural also happening
however the short answer to your question is yeah
I definitely I definitely found myself going down
the rabbit hole of thinking there's some ghostly
entity element more because of the first movie did
you like this even in the same category as the
first movie like I I think that you like this
one less but did you like it close to as much or
for you was the first movie just a significantly
better movie I think the first movie is a tighter
film I think the first movie is a stronger film
um but there are elements here that I really
did love like the the last half of this movie
I loved I really did I this took a long time to
get there it took me I was really thinking like
I'm not sure I'm going to like this movie cuz like
I wasn't giving a [__] about anybody whereas in
the first movie we did like you and I were both
going back and forth like wow these people feel
so even though even though they're all [__]
like even though as the movie kept going you
find out they're all dicks you they felt so real
and you felt like you really got to know them um
so early on that I was more attached to it and and
the Mystery around it I thought was more alluring
right off the bat and there was also a personal
tie-in to the thing they were enveloped in and
to me this the sensibilities of that choice and
dynamic just make for a more engaging story for
me personally but the subject matter of this and
uh the cleverness of this and also the the fact
that it feels real really spoke a lot of volumes
to me and made it icky like I I I think you and I
are having like different responses when people
were kind of getting killed as I was going like
this is so evil but I was having fun with how evil
it was because it was just like damn watching hang
and I was like can't believe they're showing
us this and you're like I was like yeah this is
[__] up man like this is like this is so cruel
and like they're so clever and uh yeah that was I
thought that was really me what did you what did
you think though did you prefer it the I think
that you know the first one because we really
went in super blind we were it was like threw
us into this world which is unlike anything I've
ever seen in a movie before so it's unfair because
I'm biased that the first one to me is just like
incredible I just thought it was so wonderful I
think this is the best version of a sequel they
could possibly make though that's good that's a
good point because the first one if we just saw it
again but with different friends and the same kind
of hacker who's like out for vengeance or whatever
it they did that version already and they did the
best version of that movie so I feel like they
they was smart by making it dark web because they
went after people who didn't necessarily deserve
it they had this like it was kind of this larger
world the reason it reminded me of purge is in
the first Purge that I watched It's just in the
house and in the second Purge we go out into
the world and this kind of felt like that in
the first unfriended were just it's an isolated
story but in the second one we see this is game
night for tens of thousands of people voting
on who lives and dies and how uh and it just
felt like a more evil society and world with
the chirons and I think that that was really
clever and different and the best sequel we could
get from this even though it wasn't as Innovative
as the first one because I hadn't seen a movie
like that yeah to me it really just comes down to
the the the the the in I keep bringing it up the
investment of the of the core cast of characters
and it's not it's not solely like just to comp
because like I said like I agree like th% with
everything you're saying you bring up like really
really strong points and especially for like what
would you do in a sequel yeah congratulations
Ro lectra Point let's go it is a question I'm
smart know I win it's it's that and it's not it's
not I'm really I'm just using this as a way to
not not to compare just to use as an example of I
guess it is a comparison ultimately the I really
felt like in the first movie that Ensemble were
real friends who've known each other a long time
you know and then here I felt Cinema I felt actors
uh cast while they were all great actors I thought
everyone did a a really great job it never quite
reached the level of I believe the history of of
them it still felt like I was still aware I was
watching actors I hear you we did spend less time
also developing that history you know I think
we were an hour and 20 minutes in when you were
like oh they went to college together yeah you
know and it's like okay so in the last one we
obviously knew who like as the secrets are being
revealed but like this person hooked up with this
person this person doesn't like this person like
as somebody was brought in the group they're like
oh my God she's the most annoying one of all of us
you know here it seemed like they were all kind of
like equal level friends and you couldn't really
tell what the Dynamics or intricacies of their
relationships were as much uh and I I think that
the actors did an amazing job too cuz there's no
real conflict between them whereas like the
first movie there's a conflict between them
well there's a conflict between him and Amaya but
we also still like uh but it kind of felt underd
yeah yeah yeah totally they were like we know
we need a conflict between them which is why she
won't go over there but what is that conflict
it's going to be very brief uh still cringing
over me in the first minute of this being like
why isn't she speaking that was so fun they're
like like if there's anything they really set
up you were like what I don't know sometimes you
know how it just takes you a minute when you're
watching a movie to like get into it and I just
I was seeing everything that was happening but
it just wasn't clicking for me Story of My Life
uh okay those were our thoughts yeah overall I'd
still give it like an eight out of 10 yeah me too
honestly I think that this is a cool franchise is
this the second and last or is this the second I
think this is the last one they made and I don't
really know what the hell I wouldn't order like
what do you pitch for a third one something Z
something uh pandemic related I feel like this
might have been it come on Roxy your thing look
at that look up I'll look up for you when it came
out this wasn't pandemic related I mean this this
feels like it was on Skype so you know it's not
pandemic related you're right that was Zoom wasn't
it um when did they could theoretically just do a
movie that takes place during the pandemic yeah
right that's what I'm saying they're all on Zoom
wearing masks mhm when did unfriended I'm going
to say it took place in 2017 yeah maybe 2018 2018
really close because I remember you reading 2016
yeah yeah unfriended three let's see if there's
going to be come they did a oh they did they did
a a thing called what rhymes with Roxy foxy no
Moxy keep going foxy there's like barely any words
that run with Roxy there's like a few words coxy
proxy proxy Jesus I said the
ones that come to mind first
coxy you got like you got like three
to four words that would r with
you what about proxy bro they did something
called unfriend I don't know what these are
I don't think there's are connected there's one
called unfriended proxy it's a short film that
they made in 2020 did they make it or somebody
made it I don't know let me see who wrote it no
no I think these guys were trying to rip off the
franchise actually is what I think we're looking
at I just to be 100% honest I would thrive in
this franchise all right yeah way to audition
yourself yep cuz I would be like what Rob with
Roxy socky all that impro for like going to Fan
out okay we got to get out of here we do um that's
it yeah that's it man okay that's it peace out
[Music] Rel